la ville de Kerson serait tombée le
ministère de la Défense russe vient de
l'annoncer ce matin des unités de
l'armée russe ont pris le contrôle total
de la capitale régionale de Kerson dans
le sud également les taux se resserrent
autour de Mario Paul melithopole une à
une les villes du crâne se retrouvent
encerclée dans le prolongement de la
Crimée déjà sous contrôle russe
à carquif une entreprise de munitions
est partie en fumée car l'armée russe
maintient la pression sur la ville
d'après les autorités ukrainiennes des
troupes russes aéroportés ont débarqué
cette nuit des combats sont toujours en
cours entre l'armée russe et les forces
du crime depuis plusieurs jours les
bombardements se sont intensifiés sur la
deuxième ville d'Ukraine située à l'est
du pays à majorité russophone
sur cette caméra de surveillance un
bâtiment officiel est frappé en plein
jour touché par un missile de croisière
russe à l'intérieur quelques instants
plus tard c'est la confusion et la
panique les secouristes évacuent les
blessés
toutes les fenêtres tous ceux qui se
trouvaient près des vitres ont été
grièvement blessées moi j'ai eu de la
chance car je marchais le dos tourné aux
fenêtres ça a volé au-dessus de moi sans
trop me toucher
même tension à Kiev ou la tour de
télévision a été bombardée hier
interrompant momentanément les
programmes au moins cinq personnes sont
mortes et 5 autres ont été blessés